well good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight Brett Kavanaugh just
finished speaking with Martha McCallum
he pushed back pretty aggressively
against attacks on his personal
integrity in his decency and he denied
completely all of the sexual allegations
against him in doing that he at times
provided a level of information about
his personal life that would have been
unthinkable just days ago through all
these years that are in question you
were a virgin that's correct
never had sexual intercourse with anyone
in high school friends through what
years in college since we're probing
into your personal yes many years after
I'll leave it at that many years after
Wow not your conventional interview he
was asked repeatedly by Martha again
about the accusations against him his
wife sat by him as he denied all of them
I'm not going to let false accusations
drive us out of this process and
we're looking for a fair process where I
could be heard and defend the my
integrity my lifelong record nobody
expected anything like this when that
confirmation process start we're gonna
have more from Martha's interview with
Brett Kavanaugh and his wife Martha
herself will join us on the set a little
bit later in the show to tell us what it
was like in that room but first we
typically open this hour by talking to
someone we disagree with we believe in
straightforward debate on this show
Americans have been talking through
their differences for more than 200
years and it's worked pretty well we
think all of us reach wiser conclusions
when both sides have their say when
everybody gets to talk and we'll
continue to do that but tonight we want
to pause for a minute we'll invite
guests on later in the hour first though
it's worth considering what we've
learned from the debate over Brett
Cavanaugh's nomination to the Supreme
Court this feels like a turning point
something entirely new in the life of
this country we certainly had bitter and
partisan debates over judicial
nominations before a lot of them Robert
Bork in 87 Clarence Thomas four years
later there many others shortly after
being reelected president in 1936
Franklin Roosevelt tried to take over
the entire judicial branch of government
packing the court with extra Democrats
so he could impose his program on
Congress by force thankfully FDR failed
in that but the point is a lot of this
is not new politics has always intruded
on our justice system Congress confirms
the nominees so it's inherently
political always has been yet some of
this we have not seen before it's
entirely new never in our lifetimes have
sitting members of Congress attacked our
justice system as they now are lawmakers
haven't mocked the idea of due process
or called for the collective punishment
of American citizens or declared that
the burden of proof is on the accused
rather than the accuser all of that is
happening right now in Washington and
more it's not just Brett Kavanaugh who's
under assault elected officials have
announced they no longer believe in our
Western understanding of justice there's
no precedent for that here it's stunning
you should pay close attention to what's
happening because it could affect all of
us the shift began late last week with
these remarks from Hawaii Senator mazie
Hirono watch I just want to say to the
men in this country just
shut up and step up do the right thing
for a change not only do women like dr.
Ford who bravely comes forward need to
be heard but they need to be believed so
there you have it all men are guilty not
because they've been proved guilty but
because they are men they are inherently
guilty by their nature all women must be
believed not because we can show they're
telling the truth but because they are
female evidence is irrelevant in both
cases all that matters is DNA all of us
are condemned or redeemed at birth and
there's nothing any of us can do to
change that it's baked in the cake
that's what she said no living US
senator has ever said anything like that
in public yet none of her Ono's
democratic colleagues recoiled or even
scolded her suggested she was wrong they
seem to agree with what she said her
owner herself did not issue an apology
or a clarification she kept going here
she is from over the weekend doesn't
Cavanaugh have the same presumption of
innocence as anyone else in America I
put his denial in the context of
everything that I know about him in
terms of how he approaches his cases
well give her credit for directness
according to senator Hirono Brett
Kavanaugh is not protected by the United
States Constitution he does not enjoy
the presumption of innocence Cavanaugh
is guilty because his opponents say he
is guilty that is senator Hirono is
position she is proud of it she's become
a folk hero on the left for saying that
watch I'll say it again from earlier
today can you clarify what you met do
you believe judge Cavanaugh does deserve
a presumption of innocence or not
look we're not in a court of law we're
actually in a court of credibility at
this point and without having the the
FBI report or some semblance of trying
to get corroboration we are left with
the credibility of the two witnesses Oh
a court of credibility now senator
Hirono didn't explain exactly what a
court of credibility is that you can be
sure you wouldn't ever want to be tried
in one though at this rate sorry you may
be if the Bill of Rights doesn't apply
to Brett Kavanaugh it probably doesn't
apply to you either
it all
I want mazie Hirono thinks of your
political views if she agrees with you
you'll be fine if not you won't be fine
keep in mind that once you've been
accused in this new court of credibility
you're responsible for proving yourself
innocent it's your job to unconvicted
sends like a mirror image of our actual
justice system you're right it is for
more than a thousand years the burden of
proof in the West has fallen on the
accuser in our country that would be the
government if they say you did it they
have to prove that you did it but not
anymore
here's Senator Richard Blumenthal of
Connecticut from this morning explaining
how the new system works we have a
constitutional duty to get to the bottom
of these allegations they are serious
and credible and now the person with the
most knowledge about them namely judge
Brett Kavanaugh has a responsibility to
come forward with evidence to rebut them
got that we accuse you of a felony your
job is to show you're innocent you're a
sex criminal prove you're not senator
Blumenthal went to Yale Law School do
you learn that concept in his classes
there probably not it's a new idea but
it's also a very old idea it was common
during the medieval period where the
accused also had a quote responsibility
to come forward with evidence to rebut
the charges against them heretics who
survived torture sometimes got declared
innocent all right but there's a flip
side to the new system because the
accused are guilty by definition the
accuser suddenly have no responsibility
to make credible claims and we're seeing
that principle in action too we covered
the story all last week five nights in a
row we said that we are giving Christine
Ford every benefit of every doubt and we
did that but let's be honest now not
many of her claims would hold up in an
actual court the one governed by the
justice system we thought we had until
about 10 days ago and mazie Hirono
informed us otherwise when did this
alleged assault take place Ford can't
say when did it happen
she doesn't know where the witnesses to
this well there aren't any the few
people Ford has named deny it happened
when was this first reported to
authorities
what never really was the story came out
in stages it was a recovered memory
apparently summoned by a psychotherapist
30 years after the fact and even then it
was another six years before Ford named
Brett Kavanaugh specifically at exactly
the point he was being nominated for the
Supreme Court
that's not our analysis of the case it's
the position of Ford's lawyer nearly all
of whom double as Democratic Party
activists and operatives and some of
whom defended Bill Clinton from far
graver sexual assault claims when he was
accused that doesn't mean Ford is lying
but it does raise legitimate question so
there's a lot of her behavior last week
for example Ford told senators she
couldn't come to Washington to testify
because she's afraid to fly on airplanes
this fear she explained is a direct
result of being groped over close by
Brett Kavanaugh back in high school in
the 80s as one of her friends told The
Washington Post airplanes cabins remind
Ford of the trauma their quote the
ultimate closed space where you cannot
get away but wait is this true Ford has
relatives on the East Coast according to
published account she's been here
recently did she drive back and forth to
California every time she visited we
don't know then last week the New York
Times reported that Ford did graduate
work at the University of Hawaii that's
sudden Island thousands of miles in the
Pacific how exactly did she get there
could it be possible that Ford is
claiming she can't fly in order to delay
the proceedings long enough that Brett
Kavanaugh can't be confirmed there might
be something that committee could ask
her if she shows up on Thursday as she
says she will they probably won't ask
her though that would be victim shaming
she's a woman she's telling the truth no
matter what she says even when things
she says turn out to be not true they
are still true by definition watch
former Michigan Governor jennifer
Granholm explained this principal
Cavanaugh judge Smith and her friend
Leland Leland Kaiser have all said they
don't remember anything like this ever
happened and Leland Kyle Kaiser who says
she believes for it says that she
doesn't even remember ever being at a
party where Cavanaugh was present right
and and that actually corroborates
Ford's story which is that she was so
horrified by this that she kind of snuck
out or slunk out of this apartment is in
a way that no one would know what
happened because she was so
utterly mortified are you following this
at home see if you can track the
reasoning here when you're corroborating
witnesses can't corroborate your story
the one you say that can corroborate
your story has still been corroborated
maybe even more so those are the new
rules here in the court of credibility
they're certainly the rules Washington
is applying to the new story that the
New Yorker magazine dropped last night
in it one of Cavanaugh's classmates at
Yale says that during a drunken party on
campus Cavanaugh once wagged his
genitals in her face
well that sounds awful and damning but
wait here's the magazine's description
of those claims quote in her initials
conversations with the New Yorker the
accuser was reluctant to characterize
Cavanaugh's role in the alleged incident
with certainty after six days of
carefully assessing her memories and
consulting with her attorney she felt
confident enough of her recollections to
say that she remembers Cavanaugh had
exposed himself at a drunken dormitory
party so it turns out she didn't
actually remember what happened none of
the people she says were in the room
remember it happening either yet after
talking to her lawyer for a week she
suddenly remembers it that's enough for
CNN guilty as charged
string him up are they all lies perhaps
but you know it certainly has the ring
of truth to me the idea that it's all
made up seems sort of preposterous at
this point oh it has the ring of truth
though perfect that's enough let's hang
him this is a bad joke this whole thing
that's clear at this point and everybody
knows it on both sides what's amazing is
that Republicans for some reason are
still playing along last week Senate
Republicans declared in effect that all
allegations against Brett Kavanaugh must
be heard I'm going to have frivolous or
obviously fraudulent they are Senate
Republicans are the ones who made the
Court of credibility possible in this
country should have surprised anyone the
new yorker ran this piece how many more
pieces like it are coming as many as it
takes no question about that we can't
control the Senate Republicans obviously
they exist in their own world but we can
remind them what is at stake here if
Brett Kavanaugh who's a mainstream judge
a moderate really a man who's literally
married to george w bush's assist
can't get confirmed the Supreme Court
then no Republican can get confirmed the
Supreme Court even with the Republican
Congress ever but it's worse than that
there's a midterm election just weeks
from now if you're a Republican you may
be wondering why should I bother to vote
you back Trump two years ago your
brother-in-law from Brooklyn Mach G Ford
so did a lot of other people but you did
it anyway why because you wanted secure
borders you wanted an end to Obamacare
and you wanted non crazy people on the
Supreme Court of the United States you
didn't get the first two you're starting
to realize you probably never will get
them but the Supreme Court that ought to
be easy and yet somehow we're all
discovering it's not easy why is that
well there's a really simple reason
Republicans in the Senate don't really
care about you if they did care about
you they would protect you
that's what you do for people you care
about you protect them if the
Republicans cared they would protect you
from the foreign invasion our
immigration system has become they
protect your children from the torrent
of mandatory propaganda they face in
schools that are bankrupting you they
protect your privacy and your freedom of
speech freedom of worship from the tech
monopolies that seek to crush all of
those things and they protect Brett
Kavanaugh from the obvious smears that
are throwing his family and his life but
they won't protect him and they won't
protect him for the same reasons they
won't protect you because it's hard and
embarrassing well because they just
don't feel like it this could be a
socialist country in a few years it's
moving that way a lot of us would like
to be protected from that our
representatives don't seem to notice
good luck on November gentlemen